[Musique]
quel sera le traité moldu utilisez-vous
une tasse ou quelque chose de stupide Darby intimidateur
double DI ne me secouez pas durement notre boule de butin
avez-vous vu le plongeon sur une chose que Jimmy a
bien manqué croyez-vous en vous
allez  [ __ ] tu es debout tard ouais tu dois
trouver de nouveaux kakis Apple demócrata
mataji mr.  Bundy pour toi magnifique
c'est notre fils de departamento hmm la
liberté ensoleillée est à propos de ces chansons deal on
move D professeur pour jouer Jane Chu je fais de
bons conseils ne vois pas ne me vois pas
nouveau Timmy est sur le papillon ouais voiture
hey maman Eng  trouver lundi
c'est votre défense terminée votre
misérable vu il y a une bonne dose
tout au long du bar donc pour le
look agua exact nous sommes désolés de vous déranger un
petit conseil lavez vos pieds pourrait
vouloir aller après tout le BA ci-dessous
j'aime le côté non  quart de bus tu n'es qu'une
tornade arbres oh mon dieu j'ai essayé d'outiller
cette poupée
le monde de la mauvaise chose ouais ha ha
ha bébé elle ha elle verbalement je suis vraiment
heureux ici
Jane pourrait ma suprématie oh hé Shinohara a
capturé Yahshua loopy loopy  agence ha
ha ha bien sûr qu'elle ne pouvait pas voir le whisky
juvie prévu dessus baby doll ne sais pas
pop ne bouge pas vers toi si je n'ai pas
notre conviction une vodka soda un fouineur se qualifie
pour Bernie cette palette alors à toi notre
volovat  faire du yoga raisonnement kebab voiture Loomis
[Musique]
Th  ank You effronté Murphy s'il vous plaît ici
c'est au Philly voir quand vous allez y'all
eu LA dans un pays où venez jusqu'à 300
votre voiture était de ce problème calmement
Dumas communica dit plat difficile
expliquez transpirez le double
à vous deux airplay
mettre à jour ils  ne reviens pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]